نحن ننظر أيضًا إلى منطقتنا
ونريدها أن تكون نموذجًا يحتذى به في
المنطقة ونشجع الكثير
من البلدان من حولنا على إجراء
إصلاح حقيقي ونغير الطريقة التي
نقدم بها المساعدة والمساعدة الإنمائية
وفقًا لمنظمة التعاون الاقتصادي والتنمية.  تحتل المملكة العربية
السعودية المرتبة الأولى في
المساعدة الإنمائية الرسمية عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالحكومة الوطنية وقد اعتدنا على تقديم المنح
والودائع المباشرة دون
قيود ، ونحن نغير من
عملنا مع مؤسسات متعددة الأطراف
لنقول في الواقع إننا بحاجة إلى رؤية الإصلاحات
التي نفرض ضرائب عليها.  موظفينا
نتوقع أيضًا أن يفعل الآخرون الشيء نفسه
لبذل جهودهم ونريد مساعدتك ولكننا
نريد منك أيضًا أن تقوم بدورك